think broadcast 2022 including featured
speakers sessions and on-demand labs all
on this episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
well folks it's that time of year again
ibm's annual think event is back in 2022
in exciting new ways
i want to focus this episode on the
think broadcast portion a free digital
event happening may 10th and 11th that
is open to one and all
think broadcast is a completely new live
streaming experience delivered in a
roundtable newsdesk format
by tuning in to the free event you'll be
able to see q a discussions with ibm
experts clients innovation talk speakers
partners and analysts across more than
20 real-time conversation segments
no registration no forms no fees think
digital is open to everyone
the live experience even has
simultaneous audio translation in
english french german spanish and
portuguese i'm going to put a link to
the think broadcast site up here and
down below in the description so make
sure you check it out for the full
details
we've got a ton of brilliant and amazing
people participating in think broadcast
and just a few of the featured speakers
include arvind krishna our fearless
leader and chairman and ceo of ibm brian
young co-founder and ceo of home lending
pal
rania khalaf chief information and data
officer of inari and dario gill director
of research for ibm and a true legend of
think
think broadcast day one will have
speakers exploring real world scenarios
and sharing how the creative use of
technology is solving major problems a
few of the main themes will be leading
in a changing world modernizing business
with hybrid cloud and putting
sustainability strategy into action
think broadcast date two will have
leaders and innovators share stories of
inspiration and digital transformation
main topics for these sessions include
rethinking business and i t operations
with ai and automation
preparing for next wave cyber security
threats and looking to the future of
technology
if you're looking to dive even deeper
during think broadcast and get your
hands a bit dirty i encourage you to
check out think academy think academy
allows you to conveniently learn new
skills at your own pace with self-paced
labs
the labs are available from may 10th to
june 30th of this year so you can take
your time with learning or race your way
through as many as possible
simply register for free through the
think academy site and you'll have
access to dozens of available courses
including building your first ai chat
bot with zero coding
coding java in a kubernetes world an
observability of a hybrid cloud
application using instanta
i'll drop the link to the full catalog
of labs in the description below so
check it out sign up and get to learning
i hope you all will tune in to think
broadcast 2022 to check out all the cool
stuff we've got going on
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now